Scott Disick and Sophia Ritchie's  rumored romance heats up  [Music]  Kourtney Kardashian's 34 year old baby  daddy seems to be moving on from their  relationship with 19 year old Sophia  Ricci the pair was spotted in Miami over  the weekend taking a romantic stroll on  the beach  Sophia rocking a red bikini top black  pants and Sonny's while Scott donned a  black Gucci shirt matching shorts and  shades the two also shared some major  PDA while boating with friends  and a kiss while at dinner during a  mystery celebration seemingly  congratulating them with cake and  sparklers the model and the reality star  have been rumoured to be an item since  they were first seen together getting  close in kanne France in May but Sophia  shut down the rumours at the time on  Twitter stating they were quote just  friends  [Music]  you  [Music]